I actually kind of I'm carried away with
my own rhetorics night mark and I love
the idea of a permanent independent
counsel who investigates everybody in
power and why not why stop with
lawmakers
why wouldn't he get into the guys who
run Google and Facebook I mean just sort
of someone who's you know isn't
encumbered by the corruption of the DOJ
and who has an endless budget what's
wrong with that yeah that's right
because there's there's millions and
millions of people and there's laws
against everything and if you happen to
be the guy that they decide to look into
they can find something or they can turn
your associates or in this case they can
put the squeeze on your lawyer which I
don't care what the congressman says I
find what happened with Michael Cohen
absolutely repulsive lawyer-client
privilege is something that was
established by Elizabethan times as a
basic principle of common law the idea
that you you you kick the guy's door
down and you take everything and we're
supposed to be reassured because the
prosecutors colleague who's not working
on the case will go through everything
and decide what is or isn't covered by
attorney-client privilege is ludicrous
I'm sorry I have to interrupt you there
you're not from this country so you may
not read the New York Times but they
assured us two days ago the if you're
not guilty you shouldn't worry about a
certain client privilege that the
president Lee has no cause for worry and
no cause to hold on to that secret
ancient right if he isn't a criminal so
why should he need my wire I saw that in
the New York Times and what was also
interesting to me is that the story
began by announcing that they'd been
briefed by three people involved with
the investigation so we've already got
three people leaking to the New York
Times that that there's nothing to worry
about that if they do if this other guy
who goes through all the stuff does
happen to come across something
interesting he's not going to leak it
like the three guys who've already
leaked it federal justice I'll get
annoyed because that congressman was far
too sanguine tugger federal justice is a
toilet
in this country it operates on blackmail
because everybody know Michael Cohen
knows that if you get dragged into court
they have a 97 percent conviction rate
because that's I mean that Soviet level
is a really 97 percent that's right now
if they take you into court they it's 97
percent and so and so these guys they
say well we lean on him and you say
you're looking at 30 years injure their
supposedly looking at Michael Cohen
because he had a New York taxi medallion
business he ran a fleet of New York taxi
cabs nobody you're not telling me that
in whatever hotel room he was sitting at
that he had his New York taxicab
documents from a decade ago and was
shredding them in the on the 37th floor
of the Comfort Inn or whatever the hell
he was in I mean this is corrupt and and
if Donald Trump is looking for a
replacement for the useless Jeff
Sessions I'll gladly volunteer because
federal justices of this grace and
someone needs to clean at the same time
Tucker while I'm getting annoyed here
the FBI won't hand over the unredacted
communication to Congress that started
all this thing so we have an
out-of-control federal prosecutor who
can seize everything he wants from his
subjects lawyer and the FBI who work for
you and the American people won't even
hand over to Congress the unredacted
document that started this federal
justice is corrupt and needs someone
serious cleaning it up and if Jeff
Sessions won't do it he should get out
of the way and make way for someone who
would I don't know why the president
would need a lawyer if he's innocent why
don't any of us need lawyers if we're
innocent no no no there's no such that's
true that's true
more marks time twice to New York Times
editors and New York Times journalist
let's all go and poke around in all
their stuff after all if they're
innocent they've got nothing to fear
yeah
give me your the password to your Gmail
if you're innocent